[Music]
[Music]
these are cleveland county children
we like to think they're healthy happy
children
or are these children of ours really so
healthy all
[Music]
can you call anyone healthy with teeth
like these in his mouth
[Music]
bad teeth are too high a price for any
child to have to pay for civic
carelessness
any community can save its children's
teeth we proved that right here in
cleveland county
but where do you start
what steps do you take
yes how can we organize our town for
dental health
how
well these ideas have worked for us and
other towns
begin by encouraging your dentist to
take the lead
they'll want to help for they know that
almost every person suffers from some
dental disease
that more than 9 out of 10 children have
one or more decayed teeth by the time
they're six
that the army has to provide nearly a
thousand fillings and extractions for
every hundred men inducted
get your local dental association to
work with you it's an organization that
knows the facts on tooth decay one that
can help you plan constructive action
then rouse community-wide support work
with civic clubs church groups
parent-teacher associations the local
health department reach out to every
corner of your county the schools the
organizations towns and rural areas
alike show every member of your
community how vital it is to strike a
tooth decay and build dental health now
[Music]
leaders of our dental health drive sent
a delegation to the state capitol at
oklahoma city they asked dr frank
burkham director of prevented dentistry
of the state department of health to
help them get a sodium fluoride
demonstration team to visit norman the
cleveland county seat
these teams were set up to aid in
familiarizing both dentists and public
with a new and revolutionary technique
for cutting down tooth decay the sodium
fluoride treatment
[Music]
dr bertram agreed to cooperate and
detailed plans for a countywide campaign
were worked out
soon its scope was expended far beyond
the mere promotion of the fluoride
demonstration till it became a drive for
a broad integrated program covering the
whole field of dental health
in developing such a campaign it's
essential that teachers get their share
of training background information for
the dental health program centers in the
schools if we're to save teeth the
biggest part of the job must be done
with children before bad practices take
their toll
teachers in turn carry the campaign into
the classrooms
the youngsters have fun with all sorts
of projects linked to the program they
draw pictures write essays make posters
and they pick up a lot of information
about dental hygiene too
soft drinks and candy encourage tooth
decay
children must learn to avoid them
in one of our schools the student health
council took up the problem the
delegates couldn't see any reason for
keeping such tooth destroyers in the
schools
so by their own vote they ask that all
soft drink and candy vending machines be
removed
now the old machines are gone replaced
by something a whole lot better
[Music]
some schools have even staged sodium
fluoride pageants they help educate
parents as well as children to the fact
that topical application of sodium
fluoride can cut tooth decay by 40
percent or more
[Music]
do
once mother and dad understand the
importance of topical application of
sodium fluoride they are more than happy
to cooperate
[Music]
when the groundwork of dental health
education has been laid the
demonstration team went to work in our
schools applying the solution to our
children's teeth teaching our dentists
and public health workers approved
fluoridation technique treating
youngsters from every corner of the
county
[Music]
the topical application process itself
is quick simple and painless
first each child's teeth are cleaned
[Music]
from
[Music]
next they're dried
[Music]
then they're painted with a two percent
sodium fluoride solution four times from
two to seven days apart
tooth decay is cut forty percent when
four such treatments are given at proper
intervals during childhood
[Music]
but the team's job is just to
demonstrate the treatment it can handle
only a small proportion of any
community's children during its brief
stay
that means you'll probably have to raise
money to continue the work cash to care
for all
if you live where there's a city water
system you'll probably want your
community to install a simple fluoride
feeder such as this one
such a unit injects the proper amount of
fluorine into your drinking water you
can expect it to slice child tooth decay
as much as sixty percent and it only
costs about ten cents per person per
year once the equipment is installed
[Music]
oklahoma's state board of health has
already outlined the correct procedure
for your town to follow in arranging for
fluoridation there's nothing at all
complicated about it
[Music]
start by getting an okay from your local
physicians and dentists and health
department
[Music]
then ask your city council to enact a
fluoridation ordinance once it's passed
equipment to feed florine into the water
system can be purchased and installed
but fluoridation and education can't
eliminate all tooth troubles there's
still a vital need for regular dental
care that means more work more money
more concentration on this continuing
four-point program to blast your target
tooth decay
first build a strong dental health
committee
second teach your town tooth care
third provide fluoridation for all
topically or in drinking water and
fourth make available regular
professional dental care
this then is one way to organize for
dental health
one way to tackle tooth decay
these are some of the things we and
others have done the things your
community too can do
a hard job
yes sometimes uniting people behind any
program takes effort but that's the way
with almost anything worthwhile and what
could be more worthwhile than the fight
for better health better teeth less
dental pain for your communities boys
and girls
[Music]
you